I think you know no I think that we
hardly have an inkling as to the real
nature of the world and the real history
of life on this planet and you know we
don't know how narrowly channeled the
manifestation of organic intelligence is
does it always have to be in a body does
it always have to be in a body that
stands upright with binocular vision I
think the real task with dealing with
extraterrestrials is to know when you've
got one it's completely silly to search
the galaxy with radio telescopes for a
radio civilisation I mean to my mind
that is as chuckle-headed as deciding
you're going to search the galaxy for a
decent Italian restaurant I mean it
doesn't work like that firm well then if
you look at the mushroom it's a curious
combination of artifact and entity it
looks sort of manufactured there's very
little fat on that system the other
thing is then the spore looks perfectly
designed to sustain itself in outer
space if you want to store spores for
longevity you create conditions as close
to the conditions in outer space as you
possibly can high vacuum very low
temperature the casing of a spore is
what is one of the most electron dense
organic materials in nature so electron
dense that it approximates a metal well
global currents can form on the quasi
metallic surface of an airborne spore
and they act as a further repellent for
hard radiation so and
you know percolating through the galaxy
at an ordinary rate typical of stellar
material mushroom species could
percolate from one side of the galaxy to
the other in under 400,000 years
well that's lightning speed compared to
the size and age of the universe if we
were to gain the power to design
ourselves I think after a whole bunch of
you know Madonna and Robert Redford
clones we would probably move on to
becoming something very much like a
mushroom it's you know mile it's
non-invasive it's at the bottom of the
food chain it's virtually immortal it's
laden with neurotransmitters and it's
living in the imagination